good morning everyone it is 10 30 and
we're gonna go ahead and open up the
environment and ag committee this
morning we have
very special guests
former chairs of this committee from who
now represent the council of state
government and they're going to do a
presentation for us and get us up to
speed on
what they've been doing so
if you'd like to come on up and take the
seat we'd love to have your presentation
don't forget to turn your mic on there
if you don't want to share mics you
could grab that one off the desk all
after 16 years we share
fair enough longer than most married
couples that's that is probably true
[Laughter]
well the floor is yours so take it away
we look forward to it
thank you everyone for allowing us to
come back home
um
as
your chair just said i'm former
representative tara assad from walpole
new hampshire right on the connecticut
river the prettiest town in the entire
world and the one with more dairy farms
uh
i'm bob heffner i'm from hudson
we both spent 10 years here in the
legislature and on this committee and it
tara is a democrat i'm a republican
and we used to swap chairs every term
uh because the majority would change and
we'd
just swap chairs
uh but we've gotten along great ever
since and
we now work for the council of state
governments as agriculture policy
advisors
so we actually share the job um as a job
sharing thing just so that we could
continue working together which is nice
council of state governments i don't
know do all of you know what it is have
you heard of council of state
governments it's similar to ncsl i don't
know if you've heard of that too
it's a membership organization
all these states in the country
pay in the legislatures pay in for the
membership dues and that's what supports
us in exchange for which you get
research services you get socialization
with other representatives at
conferences and policy summits we do
blogs we do research we do
newsletters
but what we do mostly is we bring people
together with legislators that are on
the same committees in other states so
that you can meet them talk to them and
find out what's going on come up with
ideas about what legislation you may
want to
propose for the next session
and just
find out that there's more to
legislation than just new hampshire
there are states all around us that do
things differently but they do it for
the same goal and it's fascinating it
really is so that's what we do
um it is an organization that's been
around since
[Music]
1936 or something like that we've been
around for a long time
and we are in the eastern region of this
national organization which means we
have 11 northeastern states starting
maryland delaware pennsylvania all the
way up to all the new england states
five eastern canadian provinces
and two territories puerto rico and the
virgin islands so that's who we
serve and we have the opportunity to go
around and visit the state houses of all
of these member states and so that's why
we're here this is coming to our
favorite state
yeah uh
we've
been doing 11 state houses a year
uh so we we get to travel until covet
hit and then we've done very little in
the way of visiting state houses
although today we're here
thursday we're in vermont
uh it looks like we're going to
massachusetts very shortly and in may
will be in harrisburg at least so we're
getting
you want to talk about the annual
meeting i'll talk about the annual
some of the things the policy issues
that we've been dealing with lately
the main one that we've been dealing
with is the
transportation issue with goods because
of covid you know the snap the snag of
all of the trucks coming through and
what is that that is doing to
agriculture and how we can in the future
respond better to
emergencies in the transportation system
like this some things that we can do
most of which seems to be
making sure that we in our region
have a food supply that we don't need to
have things trucked in all the time
there is capacity
and so we are working as a region to try
to get that up and running a regional
food system
what other things have we talked about
we've been talking
about carbon farming
we have
uh what uh
rural broadband has been a big topic for
us
uh and and now we're going to talk about
it some more because we've got lots of
money coming in from the infrastructure
bill
uh
and
the objective now is
how do you get a hold of that money and
you and be able to use it
because this time for the first time is
going to be in the hands of the states
and not in the hands of the fcc who are
going to be doling it out
strictly to comcast or verizon or
whomever and the last mile never gets
covered and so hopefully we'll be able
to figure this out but we're going to
make sure that each state has an
infrastructure on how to dole out this
money and to whom
and it's a smooth process so that's
interesting another thing that we do
the shortage of meat processing
facilities in the state
um it's it's getting to the point where
you have to wait a year and a half just
to get your animals scheduled for
slaughter
that does not help
local food production
and so until we get either a
increase in the number of kill bays in
the area
what was it
yes 30. it's been estimated that we
didn't need another 30 kill base just to
handle the demand
in new england right and right now
no one is proposing new um
slaughterhouses because they're so
difficult to get up and running anyway
enough of what we're doing but that's
the sort of fun stuff that we're dealing
with we do this with webinars we do this
with policy summits
and we do this with our annual meeting
speaking of which our annual meeting is
actually going to be
in manchester new hampshire this year
normally we s we rotate the location of
the annual meetings um
last year well it would have been in
canada the last time we met in person it
was in pennsylvania before that it was
in connecticut before that it was in new
york
and so this time
new hampshire is going to be the host
it's going to be at the doubletree
in manchester and i have the information
here for you guys um
and also talking about what we're going
to be dealing with i left off this sheet
that we're going to be talking about
climate and the future of farming with
global warming and how
farming has to change in order to adapt
um to the different
climate
yeah in fact i'll add to that
farm bureau
howard probably remembers
three years ago maybe had
usda climatologists come in and talk to
us about
uh what
the change in the climate means to
agriculture
and
we're going to
i we we
we've got an invitation ready to go to
him but uh we're going to try and bring
him back for our annual meeting to talk
about
what what does that mean and if we do
need how do we adapt if we need to
uh
so we'll we'll see what happens with
that and
and what and you can add the next one
on what i was distracted sorry oh we're
we're also
we're also doing rural broadband
yeah we we just discussed that um
this focus is going to be on the money
end of it
um and it's very interesting
because
in the past
like i said before the large providers
were the ones who would get the money
from like the usda and the fcc and all
of that for rural broadband
this time
it's the money is being given to the
commerce department in washington who's
going to give it directly to the states
and
it's like the
providers so used to getting the money
are not happy about that
so we're going to have a nice discussion
including them to talk about their
position like why they deserve to have
the money and then we're going to be
talking to municipalities and cities
saying this is why we need the money so
another
another thing that we normally do at our
meetings in will this year
our but we have three
work sessions uh the first one is always
a round table of states and provinces
we go around and get all 18
jurisdictions that we're responsible for
and they give us a three-minute update
on what's going on in their state what
are the important things that they're
working on and what and what are the big
issues they have
and then we follow that
with
one of the csg people who's down in
washington comes in and he talks about
everything agriculture that's happening
in washington
oh speaking of which this coming year is
going to be the farm bill they're going
to be voting on a new farm bill and that
is so important to every aspect of our
lives
services like
school meals school breakfast school
lunches things like that um
snap benefits all of those are covered
by the farm bill you're talking
trillions of dollars that is going to be
decided
in the farm bill and if it's got i think
10 titles 11 titles something like that
underneath this one mega bill
dealing with conservation dealing with
commodity prices can it's so huge but if
we in the northeast don't work together
to actually come up with what we want in
this farm bill
we won't get any recognition because
each of our states is small like if new
hampshire goes into washington and says
you know we would like some money for
specialty crops they would laugh us out
of the room because we're so small but
if we as a whole group go in with new
york pennsylvania
all of the new england states and
maryland and delaware
they'll think twice about you know
laughing us out of the room because we
have more representation yeah to that
point
if you take our
congressional delegation from the 11
northeastern states we're 21
of congress
so
working together we have some clout
not working together we have none
uh
yeah
who's going to listen to
two reps from new hampshire but when you
put us all together we've we've got a
lot of clout
so in the annual meeting in addition to
discussing these things we come up with
resolutions
that actually get sent on to congress
telling what we want
last year we came up with a resolution
requiring truth and labeling so if
something is saying it's soy milk
and it's not from a lactating animal
then it's not milk and no one is
enforcing that actual rule
people continue to use the word milk
when they shouldn't be and so we were
sort of demanding that they enforce this
rule because that's what the definition
is
speaking of
labeling i brought this i just saw this
this morning i thought it was hilarious
so i wanted to share with you guys um
it's about
and while she's doing that
the last time we did a farm bill which
was five years ago
uh
we also came up with a resolution for
the northeast of what we wanted to see
in the farm bill
and to make sure congress got it tara
and i
went to a
hearing on the farm bill that the house
ag committee in washington put on except
they were at suny coble skill so we went
over there
sat through their hearing
we spoke at the hearing and we gave them
a resolution so they all had a copy
so that that you're just reading i think
is hilarious a friend of mine who is a
sheep farmer out of surrey new hampshire
actually wrote this comment
in response to an advertisement that the
keen co-op
actually
put
in their advertisement
and he's not enamored of the product i
don't think
[Laughter]
so that's the sort of thing we do what i
want to do is find out what you guys
have been doing this year
um
i'm always curious as to what ena has
before it i understand that you have
some solid waste issues some pet
issues they sound familiar to me because
we've dealt with them all before in the
past
so
mr chair do you want to maybe give us a
quick rundown of the things that have
been
sailing through and things that have
been maybe not so sailing through this
year
certainly well i want to thank you for
the presentation actually can i ask you
a question first on the uh yes csg east
annual meeting yes so it says august
12th through 14th yes but the 15th and
16th of the actual meeting so is it
actually the 12th through the 16th that
was a mistake a typographical error on
my part disregard that as 15th and 16th
so it's not 12 through 14. it's 15 and
16 15 16. thank you very much no problem
i was trying to make sure i was
understanding what i was reading it it
does start a little earlier than that
and the 12th may be a good number
because we have an executive committee
meeting and uh uh
an opening dinner on sunday and so
we we started early gotcha okay
fair enough so on our committee i think
you've actually kind of highlighted what
we've done is solid waste and a few
animal issues that's been primarily what
we've done we have had a couple of other
bills relating to state fairs and
providing setting up a grant funding for
the state fairs for um
some capital issues that they may have
in fact that's in the senate that's
great good i saw that there was
something on soil what happened to that
and what was that about actually
bixby might want to cover that it was
so uh
there's a it's a study committee bill on
the soil condition
well actually our there are two bills
there's one was last
last year
there was a bill
that um updates the um
the soil statutes to include the
definitions of healthy soil and
uh
and
essentially it set things up
in the soil statutes so that
or in the soil conservation statute so
that
the um conservation districts which are
already doing a lot of stuff with
healthy healthy soil can include
the uh the charge in the statute to deal
with healthy soil when they're doing
when they're making uh when they're
filling out grant applications and that
would that the idea is that will
strengthen their hand in the grant in
the granting process because it is then
part of their mission right uh so that's
that's what that one was about
um and then
this year there is a study committee
which uh will be heard by the senate at
some point but i don't see why they
would turn it down we only put one
senator on it
and
but that is looking at the soil
conditioner stat chapter
because when howard and i were doing a
bill last year
actually the soil the soil
the healthy soil statute
there was a last minute amendment that
the senate brought in
that would make biostimulus soil bio or
plant biostimulants uh a different
category and that went into the soil
conditioner statute and when we we
started looking at the stat that that
chapter we realized well there's no
definition of a soil conditioner for one
thing
and there are a few other um
recognizable shortcomings of it and it
hasn't been really studied for a couple
decades so we thought okay time to
kind of do with this what we did with
the slaughter statute exactly three or
four times ago yeah we did solid waste
too the same way we studied it and
studied it and came up with revisions to
make it
make sense so uh so that's that was
that's what the the
soil um good bills are and i actually we
had a study committee last fall on
on slaughter facilities and we came to
the unfortunate
conclusion that this is a very real
problem and it has several
significant factors leading into it but
there's not much we can do as a
legislature to uh to mitigate those such
as you know a lack of workforce and
the
um
basically it's there need to be private
individuals who are going to come
forward and start
and and you know make the slaughter
facilities right and
we can't legislate that we've spent what
two years
when we were in trying to get a state
meat inspection program up and running
in the states so that we would have
control and not the usda
food safety which currently is and that
was shot down in washington we looked at
we looked at that we looked at this
doing a state program again and
uh came to the conclusion that it is not
financially viable for a state the size
of new hampshire to be doing i remember
that we thought the same with vermont
they started it out first they have a
state meet inspection program their
department alone for the state meet
inspection program i think had 14
full-time employees
and we were thinking in new hampshire
we're going to pass that but actually
that department is self
it's
self-funding
from all the licenses and everything and
so it doesn't really cost the state
anything to run it
and yet they now have the ability to use
their own people to
inspect
their processing facilities and they're
even getting agreements so that they can
sell the state meat inspection meet
across state lines which is even better
i mean it would be good but
whether it's going to happen here or not
what else howard so we um we did finally
get the
raw ice cream raw milk ice cream bill
through signed and it is now law good
for you so that that one is finally done
is that retail
yes
there's you know they'll allow them to
make raw milk ice cream and sell it
there's there's a few stipulations we
put on for uh you know the warnings and
things of that disclaimer okay
disclaimer and there's package sizing i
think it was right six ounce max if i
remember right so that it would be
considered individual servicing
have there been any
um unfortunate incidents of like
salmonella or anything with raw milk
that you know of over the last few years
there was a small one that occurred was
remember where it was
i can't recall where it was okay so um
bran moore farm in rollinsford rollins
yep had one heifer who
uh had a um
uh i i forget exactly what the what it
might have been chlamydia or listeria or
there was there was some
there was some bacterial problem with
one of their one of their heifers and
they did not catch it immediately
and then they had a couple of a few
customers saying i got sick and they
immediately
sent out a recall notice and basically
did everything you're supposed to do
that
to uh to mitigate the situation
uh it and
uh
so they decided that um
you know they thought they had had the
impression that they were doing all the
controls necessary that they needed and
that this had slipped through so they've
decided not to do raw milk anymore
uh but um
but one of the things that this so the
department the food safe safety division
uh
got all gun shy about raw milk of course
they did yes they tend to yes what this
actually demonstrated was
what they told us in committee several
years previously which is that if it is
a small
uh if it is a a small operation right
and
um
reasonably well traceable right then
you're just balancing risks exactly and
what happened here was that
the that that basically
went into effect there was a there was
an incident and
the you know it's a known risk and they
dealt with it
really appropriately right and you know
a few people got sick but it was not
like a massive thing all over the state
or the country do you still have it so
that it is only saleable at the farm
farm stand or farmers market yes okay
good yeah we didn't change that and we
just added basically ice cream to the
existing statue good good yum probably
one other major thing that we did was um
this year we had a bill come through
it's in the senate now uh setting the
maximum contaminant levels for pfcs and
soil
because that is related to the
saint-gobain issue and there was some
resulting soil contamination that
occurred
as far as i know it came from airbound
sources and so
we are working on that and recognizing
that it was an issue and so we've set
finally set some things in place so that
des would have something to work with
and again it's working its way through
the senate now how does that impact
farms or does it so the only concern
that i had with it potentially could be
like land spread sludge things of that
nature could potentially
contain pfcs as we saw in in maine that
occurred and okay so
that was really the area that i saw it
potentially could but otherwise i don't
think it will is sludge still a
successful operation here in
new hampshire uh it's still generally
used yes amongst typically it's dairy
farmers who are using it on yes exactly
because it's not allowable on vegetable
land as well and anything that's going
to touch the ground you know any crops
right that's kind that's certainly the
largest use of it most definitely uh
beyond that most of the other issues
we've had were related to solid waste
and we had several bills before the
committee this year on that and um we we
put out sort of a major
encompassing study committee bill that's
going to look at several issues related
to the sighting of landfills and the
associated risks and things that go with
it when we were in
because of the casella
problem in bethlehem
we came up with a bill that would have
community agreement
expansion huge expansion to the existing
landfill or siding of a new one the
community themselves had to agree to it
with the the company coming in
that unfortunately didn't pass but i
thought you need to have the community
buy into this
you know and you have to be
sort of working together instead of just
being foisted upon and both sides being
angry that's what it seems to be so well
certainly all of these issues are are
still there they're still very much a
forefront we've had you know a lot of
concerned citizens that have come in and
testified before the committee and i
mean i think the committee has
really enjoyed a good amount of
information from the industry
professionals as well as the impacted
citizens within the community so it's
it's been a good experience for us to
have that information so so um i was
just
i was just testifying in the senate on
the bill that we passed out of our
committee and uh passed on a voice vote
in the house uh
that's 14.54 14.54 which uh basically
it's a it's very simple there's an
existing setback of 200 feet and we said
we that test setback should actually be
determined by with hydrogeological data
and there should be a five-year
window
between when any spill would happen and
when
contaminated groundwater would reach a
sensitive water body and um and
that that seems to be a very nicely
targeted
uh
you know
change to
to current role good so we've got about
two more minutes here if there's one
more anything else that you want to wrap
up with before we move into our hearings
well i'll
leave it with uh
we still would like to see
some of you come to our annual meeting
after all it is in your state
howard is your appointed representative
representative to our committee at csg
uh
if he can make it we'd love to have him
if he can't
maybe he can appoint someone to go in
his stead but anybody can go yes
the problem is there's a cost to that
and i have no idea what the speaker
has for a budget this year so and we're
trying to work with our organization to
at least give a huge discount to the
representatives in the state
and we need volunteers to help people at
the registration desk and everything so
if you want to volunteer in a little
position
then you get to come to the meeting so
that's a good pitch right there
[Laughter]
well listen we want to thank you both
yeah and it it really is a great idea
when you go to those because the
networking with your counterparts in
other states is great
thanks we appreciate you coming in and
i'll certainly try and it is a busy
season for me on the farm and the
mornings are a challenge but i will
certainly try but you don't have to
travel far that is a good thing that is
very true thank you so much for allowing
us to come and and come back home thank
absolutely
so we've got about one minute before
we're going to gabble in with the next
bill anyone who wants to speak on it i
would ask you to send a pink card up in
this direction so that we can get you on
all right so it's 11 o'clock we're going
to open up the hearing on senate bill
which is relative to solid waste
management and i'm going to call on
good morning senator and welcome to
environment nag
good morning mr chairman thank you very
much and committee members
hopefully we'll be quick here we can get
out and enjoy some sun today
my name is kevin cavanaugh senator from
district 16
representing the towns of beau candia
dunbarton hooksett and manchester awards
1 2 and 12.
i'm here as a prime sponsor of senate
bill 396 legislation that requires the
department of environmental services to
contract with an engineer or hydro
hydrogeologist when evaluating a permit
for lin for a landfill
when this issue was brought forward last
year we had outstanding questions
regarding the science behind the policy
when i was placed in the committee of
conference i made a commitment to bring
forward legislation this session that
would help move forward on this critical
issue
our state parks are one of the most
significant public assets we have and we
should take take responsible steps to
protect the natural beauty that new
hampshire is known for
but we that
it also recognizes the skyrocketing cost
of recycling expenses
understanding that at times the
department of environmental services has
limited access to the necessary
resources needed to conduct the kind of
analysis outlined in this bill
this legislation puts the cost on the
applicant for the department to retain
an independent licensed professional
engineer or hydro geologist
to assist
in determining what information is
necessary to render the application
technically complete
assessing whether the application meets
the requirements for approval and
ensuring that the department processes
the application in a timely manner
this helps to ensure that a thorough
process when making a determination
about where to site these landfills
i am not sitting here today as an expert
i am sitting here as a legislator hoping
to give the experts the tools they need
in order to make informed decisions in
the best interests of both the
environment and the people of new
hampshire
thank you i'll answer any questions i
can but there's hopefully some great
experts in this field behind me
thank you senator dude we have any
questions for senator
kavanagh
representative bixby
yes so i happen to be in
the hearing for a house bill that
requires
a hydrogeologist to
do
test well samples around a prospective
uh landfill site is that the sort of
thing that this bill could help with
that's exactly where we were last year
we had the the um it was kind of an
arbitrary number of two miles in a in a
broad section of area and this is really
gives it to the experts in environmental
science the the chance to look at that
area and tell us where it should be
where it shouldn't be right thank you
thank
you any further questions
representative comptal
thank you mr chair and thank you senator
for taking my question
um in reading this bill i'm looking at
the department may enter
and uh into a written agreement and then
it says if the applicant's failure to
enter in such agreement may be grounds
to deny the application
um
there's a lot of ifs in this
um how do we
know
how does the applicant know if they
choose not to that their
application won't be denied because it
doesn't say they shall it says that they
may
and how do we know what the expense will
be to the
applicant thank you for the question and
we i did work with the department on
that because originally i had in there i
said had shell and they thought it would
be easier for the department if they did
have the resources that they can say may
and that's why it was changed to may the
the price
again would have to find out from
experts in the field what that would be
i i would have no idea what that price
would be until we um probably got a
quote from someone from the department
or
thank you
any further questions for senator
kavanagh
seeing none we thank you thank you very
much
have a good day thank you you too
is there anybody else that would like to
speak on senate bill 396 i don't have
any more pink cards
all right seeing none
the blue sheet we have
three people signed in in support online
we have 35 signed in in support and one
opposed
and with that we will close the hearing
and on senate bill 396 and our next
hearing will start in 15 minutes on
you
okay seeing as it it is now 11 20 we're
gonna open up the hearing on senate bill
367 and i'll call on senator kevin avard
to introduce the bill
welcome to environment nag
thank you representative mr chair really
appreciate it it's nice to see friendly
faces
people smiling
happy day we're always happy
it's a great committee it is a great
committee
and worthy of of all the praise that you
put in it and a lot of work we know that
and so anyway for the for the record i'm
senator kevin avart
and i am the prime sponsor of this build
sb
367 relative let's see uh
relative to regulatory status advanced
recycling and manufacturing facilities
so
i paired before you to introduce 367
relative to the regulatory status
advanced recycling and manufacturing
facilities when this bill was brought
before me i was glad to prime sponsor it
and i think
that we have a lot of bipartisan support
for this and i'm thankful for all those
who did co-sponsor with me
the bill is about
incentivizing private investment to come
to new hampshire and develop another
tool for keeping plastic out
of the landfills
i was really excited to hear that there
is an alternative we have
people that are interested in looking at
new hampshire so
we want to make sure that these plastics
are out of the landfills and
in advance and creating an advanced
recycling facility there are others here
who are going to speak to the specifics
of the industry and how the advanced
recycling works
the goal of the bill is very simple it
is to establish a clear
regulatory path
that this type of recycling facility is
treated as a manufacturing facility and
not
a solid waste facility
18 other states have passed similar laws
with the intent to attract private
investment to the states that would
bring
good jobs in stem fields and
construction as well as other
ways to recycle the hard to handle
plastics
there are no such philoso no other such
facilities in the northeast and we
should want this type of manufacturing
definitely in new hampshire
sb 367 passes
past the senate unanimously on a
bipartisan voice vote
we did amend the bill to address
questions brought forward by the
department of environmental services
about their authority and the department
was involved in drafting drafting the
amendment
and support this bill i'm pretty sure
they still do and my goal is to pass
this enabling legislation to help new
hampshire it can help with our solid
waste needs by diverting the hard to
recycle plastics from our landfills it
can help recycle and
reuse the plastics and help our economy
by bringing good manufacturing jobs
in stem fields it's a win-win for new
hampshire
we labored hard on this bill and when i
thought well there are plastics as you
know that go into the landfill that will
never be recycled
they will never be recycled they're
there and they're they're causing harm
this is an idea
that will
take that stuff
from the landfills or or prevent it from
going into the landfills which have a
lifespan in itself
and recycle it and reuse it
a lot of people you know aren't familiar
with what's going on with the landfills
and uh
and and the lifespan of those landfills
and of course when you continually dump
plastics that are not recyclable into
them they just
create a situation where the lifespan of
that that landfill will
diminish
um
we come up with good ideas
and uh one of the things that that
troubles me is that when we come up with
a good idea we got legislators later on
that didn't think they were a good idea
and we we tend to pull the rug out from
from underneath these good ideas and i
think like the bile plants is this is a
similar situation
the
the thinking outside the box
got me really excited about this bill
it really is is an idea that that its
time has come to pass and i think this
is uh i just hope that you you see it
the same way that i do
uh that we have an opportunity
to preserve our landfills and to protect
our environment with this type of
legislation so with that
i'll take any questions but if you have
any real technical questions i think the
department is here that can answer those
as well but thank you mr chair thank you
senator i'll open up with one um did you
work with the des on drafting the new
language for this bill yes
so you've addressed i know they're going
to speak but you're comfortable with
indirectly yes i did yeah yeah so you're
comfortable with the language changes
and their recommendations very much and
we hope that you are too thank you
representative kaplan
thank you mr chair and thanks for taking
my question senator
can you hear me
i can okay um i'm glad you shared a
similar concern with reducing the the
plastic from the waste stream in new
hampshire that's a great laudable aim um
representative could you get closer to
your mike yeah sorry about that i'm
reading your lips at this point
are you are you familiar with the
reduced reuse recycle paradigm for for
solving waste issues
i've in passing yes not i'm not but i've
heard something similar to that where
would a plant of this type
fit into that paradigm
in new hampshire
uh anywhere yeah
because we don't have one in new
hampshire
up in our whole area we don't have
anything that that supports us so this
is an idea that that we we need
well i mean to solve the waste crisis
however where would it fit in the
paradigm of reduced reuse recycle
because the idea is that reduction is
the is the number one
it's important but it would be in the
recycling area this is this is the third
one down it's the lowest one down uh i
guess if you want to categorize it that
way it's still part of the paradigm
right okay so it doesn't work without it
right but in terms of solving the waste
crisis we always try to reduce before we
want to reduce that's right but there
are plastics that that
nobody knows how to recycle at this
point and to be able to reuse
and recycle that's that's part of it
right
thank you representative
any other questions for the senator uh
representative bixby
yes thank you for taking my question
um
so
uh let me say at the outset that i like
the
concept of uh being able to really
recycle things that are not
as easily recycled as
um
as
you know a couple of types of bottled
plastic
but i just have some questions about
the about the language of the bill um so
in
let's see first page at line
15. uh
for the purposes of the chapter
advanced recycling facilities shall not
be considered facilities
uh solid waste facilities solid waste
management facilities i'm not quite sure
why just plain facilities would not
would be there is that something to do
with a
um
thing the way things are written in
current rule uh so shall not be
considered facilities and then commerce
solid waste facilities yeah yeah um
that's a uh
don't normally know okay yeah and and if
that might be a redundancy or something
to that effect uh maybe that could be
struck but i'm not sure okay so so maybe
that's something i should bring up with
someone from the department
uh the next um
question the next thing is at line 23
it's in the bold italics products
derived from advanced recycling shall
not be considered
waste derived products or require
certification as waste derived products
why is that line there
i think part of the discussion that we
had is that these are not
these are not
this is a manufacturing bill this is for
those products
that pertain
to manufacturing and they're considered
uh products
uh not
it's not refuge it's basically uh uh
trying to think of the word uh
secondary raw materials raw material
thank you very much it's raw material
and i think that
the the idea that this is going to end
part of a waste management
that's not what this is this is for
specifically recycling things that would
end up in waste management instead it
goes towards recycling
so
it's uh we want recycling we don't have
it in new hampshire okay follow up
yes so um
one of the things so we have a the way
i'm sure you're familiar with our waste
management pyramid that uh
has you know the you know basically
landfilling at the bottom and reusing at
the top or not making it
not having it waste in the first place
at the top and somewhere in the middle
of that is
uh is recycling and reuse
and and
um
so and this would be specifically
recycling not reuse and they're two
different categories but we're not go i
don't want a quibble about that what i
want to
uh my question is actually about uh so
that
the current waste management plan has
waste reduction and diversion goals and
i assume that the next one is going to
have those as well and i'm wondering
whether
material that is diverted from the waste
stream for this purpose would still be
considered diverted from the waste
stream and count towards our ability to
get you know keep things out of
landfills
with this line in here about it not
being considered waste
i'll let the
other people speak to that specific part
of the bill but i do believe that what
we're trying to do is reduce the amount
of plastics
that go into the landfill that cannot be
recycled
this is thinking outside the box
and
there there'll be a reduction at least
from new hampshire
of uh the plastics that are going into
the landfills
so
uh you we have some experts to talk
about whether there's a byproduct or or
something to that effect that will uh i
think will address some of your concerns
right so i'd
just to clarify mike i'm not i'm not
saying that it i i just want to make
sure that when we use this process to
avoid putting plastics into landfills
we're getting credit for it
oh we're going to get credit for it of
course this is a big feather i just
don't want to have an inverting piece of
language sort of
preventing that um
okay so did you have more you wanted to
i think i think the rest of my questions
may be better directed to uh someone
further down the line thank you very
much representative bixby any further
questions for senator mr chair there was
one over there on the right oh i'm sorry
representative murray i couldn't see you
no that's okay thank you thank you
senator for taking my question so and
this may or may not be something that
you are able to answer but i was curious
with regards to on page line four
starting
excuse me page three lines four through
thirteen roughly there
um it
when it's defining solid waste there is
reference to potential burial locations
within 75 feet of any drinking water
supply
and i was curious as to how that might
jive with
some of the other things we're
considering elsewhere with respect to
the 75 feet
and additionally
whether or not
there is an intent to bury anything why
why that statute is in there i'm going
to let the department handle that one if
that's okay
yeah they're
pretty reverse to the the technical
parts i think there was another one over
here yep i have representative stapleton
first
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
i don't see anything in the bill here
about incineration
or high heat destruction
this sounds like an industrial process
what you're forwarding in the bill
for breaking down and reutilization of
these components is that correct that's
my understanding
thank you
representative dutsy
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question um in the beginning you said
uh you uh you were asked to bring this
bill forward can you tell us who asked
you to bring the bill forward
uh yeah uh i could uh
jodie grimbles brought it to my
attention and she represented who was
that uh
jodie grimbles she is one of the
lobbyists here okay she brought it to my
attention
okay so it was the american chemistry
council that asked you to okay jody
thank you all right okay thank you
there's another question any further
questions uh representative kaplan thank
you mr chair and thank you for taking my
follow-on question
would you is it fair to say this is a
fairly new industrial process
i think there's some other states that
have have adopted it adopted the
regulation or the actual industrial
process
both okay so how many plants are in
existence
um my numbers i thought i i understood
that there were at least
six or nine
okay so i'll be i'm going to get here to
say it's not it's not a widespread
industrial process now we're going to be
the leader on that okay but yeah i mean
that's great i have no problem with
being the leader in industrial uh
processes that work but this is it's not
really a tested uh
system it's been tested in the lab it's
not been tested at commercial scale i
believe it has yeah i think you'll hear
a testimony that it has okay
were you concerned at all uh
at some of the
potential downside of the byproducts of
of a chemical and industrial process
with any manufacturing there's always a
downside whether you're a a tool and die
there's a downside you know there's
any type of manufacturing you have
there's always a downside there's always
a byproduct of something however
what we have right now is is a byproduct
going into the landfills that will never
come out
and we have no solution
and we have a bunch of fear about moving
forward and it's time we step out of
that fear and move forward with with
ideas that can
protect our environment we have that
byproduct already we already have that
downside in play and it's been in play
for multiple generations
it's time
it's time we come up with an idea that
hey
we got a plan is there a perfect plan
there's always a downside to every plan
this is thinking outside the box this is
a way to say hey look there's a
byproduct that's already there's a
downside that's already being generated
after generation after generation and
it's going into the landfills
and
we can second guess it but all we're
doing is with this particular bill
enabling
the conversation to go forward
it this does not license any particular
plant at this point but this allows the
conversation to go forward can we can we
fix it yeah
are there downsides tell me a bill that
doesn't have a downside
tell me a manufacturing company that is
all you know
i just drove to new jersey
is there a downside
uh there there may be uh but i'm not
aware of any but what we're doing right
now we're only setting the stage for the
conversation to continue
and to
instead of saying no no no
no
hey let's let's figure out a plan and
work together and this had bipartisan
support
in the senate
which in itself i'll just let you know
that's a big deal
it's a big deal thank you senator
representative bixby yeah just one more
question which is um
why is
a redefinition of of the plastics
feedstock for this
uh as not solid waste
or why actually let me phrase it
why is it an impediment to have it
i think it changes the narrative of what
what's going on and it seems as though
narratives are are a good way to kill
things good ideas and so it isn't it's
it's basically raw material that that is
being used uh if if
it's not labeled as raw material then
guess what it goes into the landfill
in the region so
we can quibble about that part of it
representative but i'm going to tell you
right now it's already going into the
landfills it's no longer going to china
anymore
they stopped that
it's going into the landfills all over
the place and
there's no plan
so i guess let me just narrow down the
question a little bit sure um
is there something about the fact that
it is currently considered solid waste
that would prevent a company from using
it as
a raw material again i'm going to go
right back to what i just said
this is just this is a purely regulatory
question maybe i should drastically yeah
maybe you should ask them okay uh
because i was a little defensive on that
because what i'm afraid of is that
they're people that like to change
uh
definitions and definitions mean
everything semantics are the atom bomb
of persuasion i learned that in high
school
all right so let's say that yes then
yeah all right representative murray one
final question
yeah i think i'll wait for des as well
okay thank you any further questions
seeing none thank you senator well wait
a minute we have one you almost got away
representative comptroller thank you mr
chair and thank you senator
uh is it possible for me to get a copy
of your written testimony of my written
testimony i don't have a written one i'm
all verbal oh yeah maybe i do yeah sure
you can have that
thank you verbiage
and this is such a nice committee i
really appreciate the questions and
friendly faces we appreciate you coming
in thank you thank you very much
okay with that i will pull up
mark sanborn from des and we'll let him
answer hopefully some of the questions
good morning for the record mark sanborn
assistant commissioner
uh new hampshire department of
environmental services
and let me start out by disappointing
you that i will not be able to answer a
lot of the technical questions
you folks have
we really would need mike wimsat and the
folks from the
division uh to answer some of the more
technical questions um i i can speak to
the work we've done uh
in terms of drafting the bill and the
fact that we feel extremely comfortable
with the access issue and authority to
review so um happy to address those uh
i'll
just make couple remarks and then answer
any questions involving that so
um
we myself and mike um winsat did assist
with the early
drafts of the um
of the bill
um and we've been working with the folks
the whole way
there was a concern about
our ability to address any
um
public health concerns at the facility
um and access to the facility
we worked with the folks who drafted the
bill to um
for an amendment that was
passed in the senate
and we feel very comfortable with the
language that isn't that amendment that
we would have
accessing any concerns at a facility
to to address any concerns and verify
any public threats etc so
we have no concerns with this taking
away any authority
to perform our regulatory
responsibilities quite the opposite we
feel the language in here
you know it reinforces that authority
when it comes to the subjects being
all right thank you um i'll i'll start
with representative kaplan since i saw
his hand first but i'll ask you
representative pull your mic a little
closer there you go thank you mr chair
and uh thank you for taking my question
um
i i just i'm curious if maybe you can
help me out here i was looking at the
senate the original bill that was
proposed to the senate and
the des amendment that went into that
bill the original one seemed to be a lot
stronger than what
what we see before us here today
so i was just like could i read you what
was in there before please
it said uh the department may enter and
inspect
to determine
oh no this is this is the new one so
what you have originally is the
department shall regulate advanced
recycling facilities as manufacturing
facilities advanced recycling facilities
in the products and byproducts shall
comply with applicable rules and
regulations that apply to manufacturing
facilities their operations products and
byproducts
and this is the the kicker the
department may make inspections to
ensure compliance
which i thought was perfectly
appropriate exactly what the state
requires what uh what you what we
require for your department to do its
due diligence to protect public health
and the environment the state
you know
reserves the right to go in and ensure
compliance with all all regulations what
we have now seems laughably
toothless in comparison and you know let
me just read it to you the department
may enter and inspect to determine
whether storage of materials prior to
advanced recycling is a nuisance or
poses a threat to the environment
the department may utilize its
enforcement authority to require
abatement of the nuisance or threat
is that what we're really concerned
about here it's like i mean i can i can
imagine an exxon mobil or a chevron
coming in here and building one of these
plants they probably have some fairly
well worked out storage capacity
are we really concerned about the
nuisance of the storage of the bottles
and not the you know the impacts on the
air or the ground water or the land use
of the products and byproducts it seems
my question specifically is why have we
walked back that enforcement authority
in the language that we see before
appreciate the question um
certainly
uh
the tone
of the two passages different versions
you
read like
there's clearly a difference in in tone
but i think in actual
authority we feel very comfortable that
the new language
gives us the same ability to address any
public
any identified concerns to public health
that the other language
i i won't disagree the original is
written stronger but i can
uh
i can confirm on behalf of the
department and mike wimsat and the
entire division that we do not think we
are giving away any of our authority we
still
have the ability to inspect um and we're
very comfortable that we haven't walked
away from any of our regulatory
authority with the new language
again agreed tone is a little different
but
that doesn't matter to us in terms of
responsibilities representative bixby
yes um
i'd just like to follow up on
uh that point a little bit uh so
the
um
it sounds like from uh what uh
representative kaplan read in the
uh
in the original bill it sounded like
requiring compliance was something that
emissions from smokestacks uh
and uh sort of the
the
um
effects of the facility on the
surrounding area and it sounds like uh
the current language is purely a matter
of managing
uh
the um the
the solid waste product which is no
longer called a solid waste product
to make sure that it meets the
conditions that are required for solid
waste products is that is there
something in here that does protect the
surrounding air and wall air
land and water quality sure all the
existing statutes that gives us the
regulatory authority
to ensure that uh you know we already
have those authorities and
in in state statute so if there's a
stack there they would be required to
obtain the necessary permits yeah i mean
we we don't have to reiterate this bill
is about a specific new
approach
um and so that's why we're comfortable
with the language in here reiterating
our authority as it comes to what's
being addressed in this bill
um it doesn't change all the existing
statute and
rules that give us the authority to
regulate
on the air and the other items you
mentioned
follow-up yes uh so
um just to follow up the uh
by changing the
definition to manufacturing as opposed
to solid waste
it will still fall under
all of the
state's
regulatory authority for
manufacturing facilities that would
include things like preventing uh air
and water pollution
the
the the activities you discussed that
could take place at a facility that are
subject to existing statute and
regulations would continue to be so okay
one more okay so um
i'm going to ask a question that uh
the senator felt that you might be more
appropriate to
to cover which is um if we define uh
the these plastics uh the the feedstock
plastics as
not solid waste
how do they get counted in the
um
the state's solid waste diversion goals
under the solid waste plan yeah so
that's a little more technical a
question than i'm
can offer but i
can commit to the committee that we will
follow up
in writing uh with the answer to any
specific technical questions as it
relates to this okay and would
yeah this is a very short one would
someone if we were to do a subcommittee
on this with someone from the department
yeah i heard there might be a working
session and mike wimsett will be here
for that okay thank you representative
murray
thank you um thank you for taking my
question with regard to the new
paragraph that is developed on page two
line eight it's paragraph i think
five
um it sets a a set of criteria for these
plastics that need to be met and i'm
assuming that it that all of a through e
must be met but it just says which all
of the following apply
so in
my reading then of subsection d where it
says the plastic has been sorted from
solid waste and other regulated waste
but may contain residual amounts of
solid waste such as organic material and
incidental contaminants or impurities
such as paper labels and metal rings
is there
a contaminant percentage much of what we
had seen in our recycling and solid
waste study committees
around plastics recycling regarded
contamination
so when we're talking about the reason
for things being refused from recycling
facilities it was due to contamination
so i'm curious to know if there's a
number
or a percentage
that if this plastic comes contaminated
what what's that metric there
that is a great question for me to get
back to you on
thank you
all right i'll remind committee members
to shut their mics off when they're done
asking questions because we can only
have so many on at a time but
representative dutzy
uh thank you for taking my question
um so my understanding in attending some
webinars on this subject is that there's
a a lot of emission there's two things
that go into it
first of all it's a highly intensive
energy
source so in other words a lot of energy
needs to go into it in order to get the
feedstock out that's number one and the
second thing is that there's a lot of
toxins that go in into the air through
this process
since it's a new pro would be a new
process in the state
do we have any uh
how would we regulate the amount of
emissions that go into the air do we
have any standards for that who would
set up those standards if we don't have
them can you give me any background on
that
well so i
my understanding
as it
relates to the air any intermission
pieces to this is
they'd be held to the existing
air
emissions standards we have so
um again that's why we're comfortable
with
the language in here
is
that doesn't impact all of our existing
regulatory and statutory authority
and the standards that already exist
so
um i i can't give you the you know the
spell out the the
numerically the standards but i mean you
know the existing state statute and
again happy to follow up with
specifically uh
okay i'm rep stapleton
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
i noticed the processes described in the
in the bill
talk about deprivation of oxygen
so it's a high heat melt factor instead
of an incineration because you want to
preserve the material for feedstock
so i would assume that
that means that the released
atmosphere is
minimal
if at all
it's contained is that correct that's my
understanding
i notice that
on page two down at the very bottom of
the bill at
roman 8 b
sub b
materials for which the united states
environmental protection agency has made
a non-waste determination
pursuant 40 cfr 241
or has otherwise determined our feed
stocks and are not solid waste
followed up
on the next page page 3 at the top at
sub d
recovered feedstock is not mixed with
solid waste or hazardous waste on site
or during processing at an advanced
recycling facility
and finally
at roman 22 the definition of solid
waste pretty clear
that these become distinct and separate
type of materials
i
is that not clear
language for what we're describing here
i'll be comfortable with it i
it
i all i can say is
you know director wimsat and all the
folks at uh the es were all very
comfortable with the way it spelled out
as you laid it out yeah thank you
representative kaplan
thanks for taking my question um i just
have a question about
regulation of manufacturing facilities
versus solid waste facilities
i know for solid waste facilities that
you have the des has the right and not
the right but you know it's part of the
plan that you go in once a year and you
actually measure
the smokestack emissions for instance or
you contract out with somebody to do
that for you but
you have that's part of the plan they go
in and do that if a manufacturing
facility is is it the same thing where
the des goes in and measures themselves
the emissions or is this a matter of
self-reporting more from the industrial
you know they're you're using the term
manufacturing generically it depends and
i mean i don't that's not criticism i'm
just saying well that's that's how it
stated here yeah it is very yeah so it
would
our what we would be regulated would be
determined by what permits they received
to operate at the facility so
you know
you
if you know a manufacturer would you
know propose plans to develop a facility
we'd let them know what permits would be
required for that and then uh depending
on what activities and what technologies
they're using
and then we would based on whatever
perimeter permits were received
the regulatory follow-up would be
dependent on you on what those permits
were so basically we have no idea the
regulatory framework here seems like a
work in progress to be honest with you
it's like it's more about what it isn't
than what it is we don't know what this
is
for you
yeah we don't know what these facilities
are because they don't really yeah i
mean
i
l as i mentioned earlier we are very
comfortable
that
nothing in this bill
relinquishes any authority we have
to
regulate various manufacturing
facilities and
if anything involving here requires a
permit
um under those activities it'll be
subject to those
those restrictions so
this is a bill identifying a new
approach to dealing with these materials
and
uh we wanted a reference in there
about our ability to inspect
if we were if there were any concerns
identified and the language that was put
in in the in the senate we feel very
comfortable does that
any further questions representative
murray
thank you mr chair for taking my
question and thank you um so yes again
on page two going back um to lines uh 25
that area
um when we're talking about pyrolysis
and um it sounds to me like this is an
anoxic environment that this would be
taking place in however there is a
mention that
there is cooling and condensation then
happening so to me there is a potential
byproduct or something potential that
might leave and head into either a stack
or an environment or be recaptured some
other way it's not really
elucidated here
and i guess that is my question
following up from representative kaplans
is in the event that
there is some sort of release in some
way
what do we do if that is not being
complied with in a way that um
our regulations and the epa's
regulations state their with the same
yeah so
yeah so that's why
again we wanted to ensure our ability to
inspect if we went in there and
inspected and identified something that
fell
under other regulatory responsibilities
in terms of air emissions etc
we'd follow up based on what we found
so
um
when there wasn't when there wasn't
anything listed in here are about our
ability to go in and inspect anything
that was identified as a concern to
public
health and uh
that's when we had concerned but
working with the sponsors of this bill
and we appreciate it
that allowing us to make sure that um
that we can go in there and inspect
based on our existing authorities um and
if we found anything that fell under
existing statute or regulations we would
follow up accordingly so we feel
very comfortable that
this will not increase any concern to
public health it's an ability to find a
new approach to dealing
with waste products
and we feel very comfortable we can do
it in a safe way
with oversight um and existing state
statutes and regulations and rules um
would allow us to follow up if something
applicable was applied
one more follow-up one follow-up and do
you feel like currently you have the
staff and the capacity to take on a new
industry such as this to monitor all of
the same things in addition to
everything else that you're charged with
well so staff questions are always a
difficult thing to talk with the
legislature because i'll go down the
hall and they'll tell me we have too
many so but um
i we we feel very comfortable existing
staff would be able to
um take this on within
our uh the existing roles we have
um and if the industry grew and that
changed
we'd identify that as a need
when it comes up to budget and staffing
but
um in these early stages we feel very
comfortable
that existing staff would be able to
follow up you know as this industry
hopefully begins here in the state
representative
oh okay
representative stapleton
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question sure are these technologies
in use now any of them described in a
bill and for how long yeah i
they are and but i'd really i'm assuming
acc is going to testify i'd really
rather let the american chemistry
council folks speak they're going to be
much more articulate about
the status of this in this country and
and other states that have implemented
it and and again but i will say this
um what our staff has learned the fact
that we wouldn't be the first state
moving forward and that this has been
implemented in a safe way did increase
our comfort level and and they'll be
able to give you a better job about some
of
that what is happening in other parts of
the country thank you follow up yes one
i believe i've heard that there are
somewhere between 500 and 1500 different
types of plastic resins
and i'm wondering if
these processes will
comprehend the
breakdown of all of them
or some of them
or not many of them how is the spectrum
work on that
again
i think that's a great question for some
of the more folks or experts on
the the technology and processes we're
talking about um
you know i i don't want to get ahead of
my skis and i i can speak to
like i said you know for the leadership
at dds we just wanted to make sure
we felt comfortable we weren't losing
any authority that you know that that
was our leadership's main concern and
um and of course always public safety
and
uh you know director wimsat um
confirmed that he was very comfortable
with the language
and very comfortable with what's in here
about the technology and if it was
implemented here and our ability to keep
public safety uh you know address any
public safety concerns so
for leadership that's where we were
coming from uh
the the the sponsors of the bill and uh
the folks from acc should we'll be able
to give you a better idea of kind of the
the process and the the chemistry aspect
of it
thank you thank you
all right see no further questions we
appreciate you coming in thank you thank
next we'll bring up uh john swann from
dalton new hampshire from save forest
lake
no sir i'm going to call you next so go
ahead
good afternoon mr chairman members of
the committee my name is john swann
i am the founder of save force lake and
i do apologize i'm a little late coming
to this bill because as you know
we've been focused on a few other bills
but uh
this was certainly one that caught my
gosh first off just starting off
there's still so many questions about
this bill
i mean
if we brought you a bill like this that
was so discombobulated
and no one speaking to testify on behalf
of it could answer your questions
i mean you would itl or is it
table it i mean
and what's shocking is the fact that and
again
i'm really concerned about this bill
because first of all
we don't know anything about it
but second it appears to be
a
deregulation of solid waste policy and
practice and standards in new hampshire
i mean we're talking about a process
here
that is still relatively unknown it's
new
as you heard from the bill's sponsor who
couldn't answer any questions about the
bill it's basically being
advanced by the american chemistry
council
so why do they want to come to new
hampshire
and why do they want to
change the language on the books what is
it about the language that prevents them
any
of their
companies they represent from coming
into new hampshire finding a site going
through the permitting process
why the change to solid waste
regulations and that's i hope you're i
mean i love the questions that are
coming from y'all because
it sounds like you're really digging
into it i would recommend that you watch
the hearing video from the senate side
just because
was it the same kind of uh hearing that
we just went through with house bill
1454 with two hours of grilling and
counter questions it was kind of a
kumbaya for a project that frankly
after that hearing
to me sounded like
someone's coming to town in new
hampshire and they're trying to pave the
way
for that project so i think that's a
question that needs to be asked maybe of
the acc or the sponsor is this a project
that's coming to new hampshire
and we all know the threat of pfas
proliferation and plastics in new
hampshire
we're familiar with that threat
and i mean this bill when i look at this
language
it just screams beefos at me in some
form or fashion
we're talking about plastics
we're talking about chemistry
i know uh
one representative mentioned it's not
incineration
but as as you've mentioned in discussion
there's high heat melting
there's processes that are taking place
and again
what's at the heart of all this
pfas
um
and i again i appreciate the fact that
the waste hierarchy was mentioned and of
course at the top is reduction
i would prefer that the bill sponsor and
the acc bring forth legislation that
would
suggest that they're actually going to
reduce
the manufacturing of these plastics that
can't be recycled
safely
and instead this bill seems to be
a
green lighting of the production of more
and more plastics in our society and we
know plastics are not good
and you know again i i'm not going to
belabor the point i did send you
a long um testimony this weekend with
questions that still remain unanswered
why can't a company come to new
hampshire with existing regulations to
site a facility like this
and
you know that's that's the key but
if there's no other new england state
that has a facility like this and we
build it it's built not weed please not
we
if it's built centrally here in new
hampshire
is maine going to build one vermont
canada massachusetts no they're going to
ship that plastic waste
to new hampshire so again think about
what the ask is here in this bill
they're asking you to change the
definition
about a
solid waste by-product
to something that is on the same level
as virgin plastic for
not recycling in terms of solid waste
but manufacturing i mean that's a big
ask that is the deregulation of probably
the largest
pain
in society's butt right now is plastic
waste and what to do with it
i mean in vermont they're even having
problem with
you know food de packaging and bits of
the micro microplastics getting in the
process and getting into the soil and
there's pfas in the soil
so again i i
i'm sorry i'm new to this bill i didn't
make it to the senate hearing on it i
would really recommend that you watch
the senate hearing
i sent you the cued link but please this
is
does new hampshire want to get into the
plastics business and do we want to be a
magnet for out-of-state plastic waste
which is going to happen instead it'll
be declassified as
whatever
pre-used polymer
so thank you
thank you will you take questions
i will certainly take questions any
questions for mr swann
all right seeing none we appreciate it
thank you have a great day
and just for the benefit of all of you
there
i'm trying to
put the cards pro and con so sometimes i
am going to mix you guys in as we go so
that it isn't all one way then all the
other and that's that's why you're
seeing it so i'm trying to get a balance
there
okay next is going to be margaret gorman
good morning welcome to the ena
committee
good morning chairman pearl and members
of the house environment committee my
name is margaret gorman i am the senior
director for the northeast region for
the american chemistry council we're a
national trade association we're based
in washington dc and cover all different
types of chemistries we have a full
plastics division i work in our
northeast regional office in albany new
york
and cover from maine to new jersey as
well so i'm really excited to be here
today and thank you for
considering sb 367
that would essentially classify advanced
recycling facilities as manufacturing
facilities in the state of new hampshire
and not solid waste this is a game
changer um right now these facilities
can take
all different hard to recycle plastics
so right now 90
of plastics are not being recycled those
are the plastics that are in the
landfills
those can come out they're all different
types of plastics ranging from so even
think in your home right um frozen
vegetables those types of bags uh
granola bar wrappers um detergent
bottles toothpaste tubes
lotion
bottles
all those different plastics can be made
and are being made into new plastics
right now there are existing projects
out there that are working philadelphia
cream cheese the next time you see a
philadelphia cream cheese tub that is
coming from advanced recycling in europe
one of our member companies plastic
energy
that is that is created out of that
magnum ice cream tubs that is another
existing project that is working in
addition to that there are new projects
that have been announced in several
areas
who doesn't love wendy's
wendy's is one they are making their new
cups out of advanced recycling
technologies they are partnering with
one of our member companies lion
delbisell to do that herbalescent
shampoo bottles that's another example
of a new project that has been announced
what's happening in the states right now
18 states have passed laws similar to
the bill that's in front of you today
closest to new hampshire is pennsylvania
virginia was passed a couple of years
ago so in addition to the american
chemistry council supporting this bill
several organizations throughout this
country are also supporting this type of
bill and the laws that are being passed
ranging from business groups to the
companies that we represent to
legislators on both sides of the aisle i
have seen legislators in other states
that have supported plastic bag
plastic
bands
in the past who are supporting and
sponsoring these type this legislation
that's in front of you today they are
saying this is part of the solution this
is a new technology actually
some of these companies i want to
address that have been in
production for 10 years
so we have right now almost actually
it's 10 facilities throughout the
country
that are
taking plastic so let me just read some
examples right now we have altera in
akron ohio 60 tons a day types of
plastics accepted choose fours fives and
sixes braven north carolina twelve
thousand tons a year they're taking twos
fours five six and sixes brightmark
ashley indiana 1 000 tons a year of
plastics they are currently taking right
now this is not a false statement this
is actually happening and those
companies want to come to the northeast
they want to invest in the northeast
because
they see themselves as part of the
solution as well so right now there are
no facilities that are set up in the
northeast
reclassifying them as manufacturing
facilities is properly classifying them
because they're making new products
they're not making solid waste so that's
why you know we thank des for working
with us on making sure that they are
properly regulated and supporting that
as well
additional states in the northeast that
have introduced legislation
new york new jersey rhode island and
connecticut
both sides of the aisle that are
supporting this type of legislation
so in conclusion i just wanted to before
you know i'm also available for
questions
the other side in the arguments that
you're hearing on the other side
incineration it's not incineration they
are not burning plastics it is a degree
issue incineration is 1500 degrees
celsius
melting at a thermal process is five to
eight hundred
the emission rate there's been a recent
study it's lower than a college campus
and hospitals they're not the emission
rates are not that high
they're also subject right now federal
loss that's health and safety standards
for air emissions which facilities must
adhere and report to they're subject to
fines permitting revocations and closure
if they exceed error emission limits so
they're not asking for
to be exempted from being you know
subject to regulation they're just
asking to be reclassified properly
because they are making new products
um
advanced recycling facilities are not
producers of any significant amount of
hazardous waste
especially you know compared to other
manufacturing processes so again they're
not burning during advanced recycling
they're using thermal energy heat
but take place in the absence of oxygen
so there's little to no combustion so i
want to make sure to address that
because you're going to hear that it's
incineration and it's 100 percent not
accurate it's not true the emission rate
again is lower than a college campus or
a hospital
so i am i thank all of you for listening
to me today and considering this
legislation
and we're very excited to be here i'm
happy to answer any questions
thank you any questions i kind of had an
idea that might be representative big
speech thank you for asking for on
taking my question
um
and uh
so
i actually have several questions but
i'll start with one um you mentioned
that uh
the the there are various new products
that are
that basically the plastic is melted
down into constituent chemicals and then
new products are made
is that all happening in the same
facility in other words does the does
the pyrolysis or gasoline or solvolysis
happen in the facility those chemicals
the you know short-term chart chains or
you know monomers etc are you know the
result of the of that pyrolysis are
those then in that same facility turned
into the new lid the new bottles for
herbal essence or is are those
is the product there shipped to a
different facility where those other
where the final product is made that's a
great question and the answer is both it
can be
uh melted into um a fuel at one facility
or it can be transferred into a product
in that same facility as well so there's
you know different facilities are doing
different types of
um recycling and that is trending again
towards new products
and i should stop for a second because
our technical expert actually isn't here
today so if there's something i can't
answer well certainly as you talk to
craig cookson who's my colleague and he
is the director of plastic
sustainability we'll certainly get those
questions that we can get answered for
you okay so i'm gonna
interrupt for just a second i have every
intention of scheduling a work uh
session on this bill
and since we don't have necessarily all
of the technical experts here today
maybe i might just say to the committee
why don't we save some of these really
technical questions for when we can have
the proper folks to answer them in our
in our work session and just so that
we're not getting bogged down on a lot
of the questions that we can't answer
today if that would be acceptable that
would that would be fine and i will um
save my quiz save the
you just cover the higher level
questions here thank you uh and one of
them you mentioned fuel and
uh one of the
uh
i did a little bit of reading about
pyrolysis etc and uh one of the uses
that pyrolysis liquids are sometimes put
to is as uh diesel fuel or other sorts
of um
fuel for vehicles or that sort of thing
is that the sort of thing that these
plants would be producing
if one were to come to new hampshire it
could be and it used to be but that's
not the trend that we're seeing now so a
lot what we're seeing now are these new
products that i mentioned and the new
projects that have been announced and i
didn't even cover all of them you know
ranging from the wendy's
project to herbal lessons so yes it
beginning did start that way and now it
is trending to new products and yes they
certainly could do that but what we're
seeing and what companies are doing now
and just a sort of a um business model
question uh so
obviously there's a lot of energy input
there's a lot of infrastructure input in
terms of collecting all the plastics so
it sounds kind of expensive uh would
directing these towards uh making new
products as opposed to diesel fuel for
does that just does that improve the the
balance sheet for doing this sort of
project
it would certainly help the balance
sheet of new hampshire economically for
sure
these
the companies that are coming in are not
asking for state subsidies or tax money
so the economic output of what is coming
out of these companies is millions of
dollars we could certainly look at new
hampshire but we've done
analysis for example on the state of new
york 500 million a year in economic
output so it's certainly i think in
addition to
the benefits of recycling
the plastics into new plastics
what a great economic output for the
state of new hampshire as well on top of
that okay thank you representative
kennedy
my question just got answered thank you
okay representative murray um yes thank
you for taking my thank you mr chair for
taking a question thank you for taking
my question
so one question i do have is with regard
to plastics that might come in that are
multi-layered that have non-stick layer
coatings of any kind or that kind of
thing that might then get melted down
into a new product
what if any
duty do we have to let folks know that
potentially those products are getting
co-mingled together and made into
something new
and
are those coatings then transferred into
the new neural products that you're
mentioning
so
the products that are coming in that are
being melted down um can be combined but
with that let me address if there's
other chemistries in that products those
chemistries are not going into the
emissions right for example um as well
they have to meet certain specifications
for these manufacturing facilities and
again that's something craig can discuss
more in the work session but they're
also subject again to federal standards
and emission rates and other chemistries
of concern that might
you're looking at i think what you're
getting at into the emission it is it
would not be going into the admissions
at all
and they they are certainly subject to
inspections and their own requirements
thank you
representative bixby if you want to turn
your mic off i'm sorry that's okay uh
representative kaplan
thanks for taking my question um
yeah i recognize that you're not a
technical expert and so i'm going to try
to keep it simple but
it's this is not incineration granted
correct
is it not a fact that that's the
emissions and the byproduct the waste
byproduct would contain toxic substances
such as dioxins infurians and heavy
metals so the emission rates are uh
lower or the same as a college campus or
hospital um it would contain levels of
those
that's something i'd have to have craig
can certainly go into that because those
substances are not safe but when you say
toxic substance can you re what specific
chemistries are you referring are you
right pfas
i'm talking more about dioxins and
furons and heavy metals which is the
stuff that usually comes out when you
burn plastics
if it was this is an incineration but
the emissions still do contain levels of
those contaminants
yes or no
that's something that i would have to
have craig certainly we can get into
more detail on that but the emission
rate the emissions do not have other
chemistries in them as i've said i mean
they're low there there have been
studies out there we can certainly talk
more about that as we get to the work
session but it's follow-up question sure
i just want to remind you representative
we're not interrogating a witness here
so let's just keep our questions trying
to be clear for the public thank you i
go ahead thank you mr chair um
are you familiar with the saint-gobain
plant in merrimack and the p5 i am
they're not a member of acc but i am
familiar with the plant and the issue
here yes i mean that's something that
we're still dealing with in new
hampshire that
that was a really you know a product of
lacks enforcement and you know
unforeseen consequences of the chemical
industry so would you agree that it
might be wise for us to to not jump into
something like this with two feet uh and
unaware of the potential downside that
is something that's potent you know
possibly huge
so these facilities have been in
existence for 10 years and not once have
these facilities been subject to any
sort of
issues with
emissions of toxins they are subject to
enforcement by the federal government
they are subject to the clean water act
they are subject to the clean water to
the clean air act they're not looking
for an exemption from
any sort of other statutes they're just
looking to be classified properly and i
think this is a great time to say
we have an actual video a great video
and looking inside of one of these
companies and what they're doing so
we'll make sure to send that to you
um after but you they're different
facilities i mean this is a facility
that takes plastics and makes them into
new plastics so we've certainly there's
been a lot of successful projects out
there
thank you actually i'm going to ask you
a question myself are there any of these
facilities being proposed in the new
england states currently do you know of
any that are on excuse me that are
seeking a permit to operate uh not yet
uh we they're in the northeast there
have not been any states yet that have
reclassified these facilities so the
closest right now is ohio there is an
existing um facility set up in ohio
already but we do know that companies
are looking to come here and invest in
in the northeast
and would that purpose be so that
they're closer to the source of the
product correct okay representative
dutsy
uh yes uh thank you for taking my call
uh
am i to believe that any kind of
plastics can go into this process for
example
if i go to christmas tree shop and i see
a plastic adirondack chair
when that breaks that can go into this
process plastic toys can go into this
process
am i correct in that
it's all different hard to recycle
plastics but the ones that we're hearing
the most that they're taking are
you're harder to recycle like your
granola bar wrappers for example and
lotion bottles polypropylene
is a higher rate so it really depends on
the commodities but yes they can take
all
hard to recycle plastics i don't have
the amount of chairs that they're taking
specifically but it would depend on the
facility and what on the outcome that
they would be looking at
follow-up sure
so what happens to my plastic detergent
bottle now because it was my
understanding that it was getting
what i can answer is that ninety percent
of plastics right now are not being
recycled and these facilities can take
detergent bottles and recycle them into
new ones
okay thank you thank you any further
questions representative kennedy
thank you for taking my question you
mentioned earlier the revenue that you
guys have mapped out to come towards
states is there also a tax reduction
have you guys looked into any of that
other than just the revenue is there a
pathway just like how
we bring in trash from other states into
our landfills the trafficking of that
material over the border to come into a
facility like this on our state would
that give us tax relief other than just
an income to the state
that's a good question i know our
facilities right now are privately
investing in other states so they're not
looking for tax breaks uh whether or not
that would happen in new hampshire you
know is a question i can't answer right
now but they're
certainly when they're looking to come
into the states they're not looking for
a state to give them a tax break they're
what about them also contributing to the
state so we get a
tax deduction so i can go into helping
pay for schools pay for stuff like that
that's something that it was a private
company um that would be up to the
company i think in the state once they
decide to come and invest it would be a
private you know decision between the
company and the state and how they want
to work that
representative stapleton
[Music]
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
um
in
in a metals process of high melt
there's often slag and dross that's
problematic but in these lower
temperatures dealing with the plastics
and resins
is there not much of that sort of thing
because you're melting to reform
that is a question where i can have
craig address more during the work
session but i know this has come up and
it's it's typically 80 of the plastics
that are recovered
follow-up sure
um
one of the big problems we have are the
blades from
uh windmill generation
for the power
and i understand they're burying these
things because they can't process them
for any given use at this point
will any of the processes here
uh enable handling
of these sort of things
handling of
the windmills windmill blades that i
don't i don't know um i would depend on
what the blades are made out of and if
it's plastic that's included so
certainly maybe a question for the work
session sure as well maybe we can save
some of these really technical questions
for the work session that may be a
fiberglass component as well as yeah it
could be represented bixby yes thank you
for taking my question so um
i'm
i have a couple of things i'm trying to
get my head around here one is uh
at what point does the uh
does does the classification change from
waste to
non to feedstock so for instance um
when uh
on the um
is it a matter of when it is collected
from you know wherever it gets collected
whether it says the
municipality has a curbside or a waste
transfer station does that does it at
that point cease to be solid waste or is
it when it enters the factory
and
what if there is not enough capacity at
the factory to handle the amount that's
coming in so that is definitely a
technical question i think i'm going to
have to defer to for craig for the work
session on the technicalities of the
feed stock and and then let me go for a
higher
and i i what i hope is not a technical
question which is
why is it that what is it about it being
regulated as
manufacturing rather than what it no
what is it about it being regulated as
solid waste right now that prevents
someone from just doing it
that prevents a company from coming in
yeah
because they're not being properly
classified because the trends are
they're making new products and in my
understanding solid waste is not
considered an actual product that's in
front of you so their trend is making
plastics into new plastics and they just
want to be classified correctly and
that's what 18 states have done we had
two states in 24 hours the other they
just enacted the same law and four other
states in the northeast that are very
interested in that because
it's just changing so much with what the
new products are are
being made into what i'm trying to get
at is are there specific regulatory
things that you have to deal with as a
solid waste facility that get in the way
of
being a manufacturer or certain things
that you have to deal with as a
manufacturer that
uh would give you an advantage if you
weren't called solid waste
i think it's on the classification i can
certainly have craig address that more
but
if they're not a solid waste facility
why should they have to come in and be
permitted as a solid waste facility i
mean if they're making new products they
should be able to be classified
properly right i'm just trying to figure
out if if you know what is what the real
impediment is because they're still
subject to permitting and des coming in
and audits and everything else so
they're not looking to get out of
anything they're just looking to
make sure they're classified correctly
okay so that they would be subject to
the right sorts correct all regulations
right thank you all right so i'm going
to ask the committee if if you don't
have any
questions that are really just general
if they're real technical can we please
hold them for the work group because
we're going to be here all afternoon
otherwise and and i think we're we don't
have the right person necessarily in
front of us as she stated to answer the
real technical questions so
representative dutzy
thank you i hope i don't think this is
technical yeah my understanding from a
study is that in 2018
we recycle 3 million tons of plastic but
we produce 35 million tons of plastic
can you give me any idea of what you
think the throughput would be
kind of an average throughput you would
see on an annual basis for this
facility
so if if i could ask where that study
what is the study that you're referring
to uh i
i don't know it was a webinar i intend
you know i didn't put down the thing it
okay just said that yeah and and it kind
of goes along with you're saying 90
percent correct we're saying the same
thing so you said 3
million tons compared to 30 million so
it would it's about 90 percent that are
not being recycled yeah correct yeah so
what would be the what would be the kind
of the expected or average throughput of
a facility in new hampshire what do you
think it would be we could definitely
drill that down for new hampshire but i
know new york if 25
of plastics were of those hard to
recycle were recycled annually
800 million ton 800 000 tons a year that
would be recycled new york that's new
york so we would have to do a comparable
to new hampshire
um but certainly you're looking at tons
and tons and tons
and just one follow-up that i mean even
based on the examples i provide in the
other states and what what the sites are
currently doing right now i caught a few
of them but i okay so
okay and the the last thing and again it
was from this webinar and basically it
said that corporate sustainability goals
will pay more for recycled resins rather
than virgin resins
and so would the residents coming out of
these facilities be considered
uh recycled or
or not because of this solid waste
facilities management type of thing
without the webinar and understanding
the webinar that you're although i think
i have an idea but um the ver it would
be taking virgin resins as well
if that answers the question i mean it
would go into the representative kaplan
yeah i hope this is a pertinent question
it references a couple of things that
you mentioned uh the first one was the
economic benefits to the state i'm
assuming you're talking about the jobs
so say there's one of these facilities
built in in new hampshire how many jobs
are we actually talking about so it
depends on the size uh so in some states
i know there's over a hundred jobs um
some have about
you're aware that there's like a five
percent or less unemployment rate right
now so it's it's a buyer's market for
jobs so i'm assuming you're talking
about good jobs like plant managers
chemical engineers those kind of how
many of those kind of jobs are we
talking
probably on the plant matter well you've
got you would have a plant manager but
on different you know chemical you need
to have chemical engineers but then
you've got construction jobs on top of
that right so you're talking good salary
paid jobs you're talking all different
how many jobs would you say i don't have
a specific announcement amount because
the company's not in new hampshire yet
so i can't i mean i can tell you what
we've done in other states
um and what we'd be looking at but until
they're set up i i don't have it exact
on how many jobs would be here
specifically i think i think we're going
to
back off on this line just a little bit
we're getting really nitty-gritty and
we're going to save that for the work
session any other questions that are not
real technical like that
all right seeing none i i appreciate you
coming in and taking giving us testimony
and the information you've provided
thank you and thank you for considering
the bill and for your time today
okay next we're going to call on john
tuthill
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee for the record my name is john
tuthill i live in acworth sullivan
county
i watched the uh
tape of the senate hearing this is a
bill actually we'd flagged when it was
still an lsr and we saw that it was
dealing with something called advanced
recycling that looked pretty positive
and innocuous
uh and unfortunately um we got sort of
tied up with some other solid waste
issues this year and uh
this one
dropped off my radar
uh until it got to the senate or it flew
through and was not getting the sort of
good
questions that this committee
has been posing today
um
sullivan county we've already been
through this we saw
trade groups and an industry come into
our region
with a proposal for some
advanced technology to deal with
waste materials and resources
the legislature did provide subsidies
and i think there's the potential for
state subsidies in this case
this is a very very broad bill
and it's highly technical it's
surprising to me when the prime sponsor
arrives and suggests that he would like
to defer questions to
the organization which
asked him to bring this legislation
forward saying that they will be in a
better position to answer questions
particularly technical questions
clearly um this organization was not
prepared for today's hearings i would
like to strongly urge
that rather than going to a work session
based on what you've seen today
and up
upon review of the senate
audio
uh back in february 8th
that you consider
finding this itl right now we're not
ready for this new hampshire
does not have the regulatory framework
or the rules in place to deal with this
emerging industry
as i say it's very broad
you're dealing with all sorts of
processes
the numbers that were cited earlier in
testimony about the the volumes of
material being processed are minute
compared to the
the amounts of plastic that are now
moving through our consumer society
really this looks to me like more of
what the
uh the now defunct american plastics
council
did for many years which is to put up
the appearance that the plastics
industry and the companies providing
their feedstocks
were effectively recycling when in fact
as was pointed out also in earlier
testimony
the amount of recycling going on with
plastic products is
is negligible
there are a couple of sorts of plastics
if you are controlling the resin quality
as was mentioned earlier this would be
far easier they're beginning to deal
with this in europe but you need to be
regulating the manufacturers and the
feedstocks carefully so that recycling
and reuse becomes possible our issue
here really is about
reduction
in these materials and the legislature
has looked at bills dealing with things
like container deposit which would
dramatically reduce the amount of
plastics
moving towards the disposal streams
and
would divert them into
effective reuse
single-use plastics have been discussed
by the legislature in recent years
i haven't seen much movement on that but
that's another way to start getting
reductions
and i think that's where the focus ought
to be rather than thinking you can come
in with
these energy-intensive technologies
dealing with what are likely to be
simply because
when you're dealing with waste it's
always looking for a place to go and
it's looking at what's the cheapest
place to go
and there's one implication of this
proposed legislation which suggests that
as soon as a truckload of material
drives through the gate that it is now
deemed to be a non-waste and no longer
prevents any sort of contamination issue
so i think it's important that des
continue to have complete regulatory
authority over these feedstocks so they
do not become used
as a place to make hard to manage
and contaminated materials uh disappear
even if it is disappearing into an
industrial process which will have some
pollution control but there are
emissions
uh you also have a solid waste
coming out the back end not slag
necessarily sometimes referred to as
char
but a lot of plastics have stabilizers
and colorants in them
you're going to be finding pfas in these
these streams whatever you want to call
it whether you want to call it waste or
not
heavy metals are in plastic for
stabilizers
you're using
metals also for colorants which is what
makes detergent bottles jump off the
shelf
you know this stuff is not innocuous and
we need to be regulating it
intelligently and carefully
i really i strongly urge you to say this
this is too complex this is far too
broad it's going to require at least
another year if the state truly wants to
open its door to this emerging industry
there
have already been efforts in new
hampshire to crack the door open i think
the senator who proposed legislation in
2016 said well we want to start small
and they did and we now have some
regulations in rsa 125c air regulations
which would be over inside tech but
they did pass legislation um supporting
pyrolysis which is one of the
technologies discussed in this bill
des went ahead and adopted rules
for the feedstock which is exactly what
needs to happen here des does have to be
involved up front making sure that these
feedstocks are not contaminated or not
increasing risk to public health in the
environment
unfortunately the rules des did adopt
for pyrolysis and the vendor that was
interested in this never did show up in
the state it was a canadian company and
it was clearly a bill designed to
encourage that investment it hasn't
happened but the the standards that were
set in the rules were
were just extraordinary in that the
levels of lead for example or been
permitted
this wasn't plastics in this case this
was construction and demolition debris
they were going to allow 10 by weight of
what are called fines which is the
particles that fall out of a processing
facility for construction and demolition
debris in this case they're looking to
make fuel
um
but
you need to be
getting up as close to the source of
the production
of hazardous materials as you can and
start regulating it there and not simply
create a doorway through which you can
pass material and then say well it's no
longer of concern
from an environmental or a public health
perspective
i really
urge you as
somebody who testified earlier did that
you do take the time to look at that
senate hearing from february 8th just
astonishing
um
the lack of
sort of thought and
even interest or the lack of questions
that were asked um
i mean i
i really felt the lobbyists
who had come in for the organization
promoting this this bill
um
i mean he just
he must not have been able to believe
his eyes
the reception he was getting and yet the
um the sponsors or at least those that
were on the committee that was hearing
the bill did not seem to have a firm
grasp of what was in the bill
um and even the representative
for the the organization today i think
really did not
uh provide this committee with enough
information to even go forward
um i'll leave it at that there's a lot
to say on this but i really urge you
um to be very careful before you open
this door as i say in sullivan county we
did see
the legislature invite an industry into
the state
back in the 80s and i keep coming before
this committee and others because we in
sullivan county paid a very very high
price
for decisions that were made here to
promote private investment in
technologies
where in fact
the real effort i believe in managing
waste is has got to be around
education behavior
and frankly beginning to limit
some of the materials that are routinely
used in consumer products thank you
thank you mr tuthill any questions
seeing none we appreciate you coming in
today
next we will call up uh heidi tremero
from clf sorry if i didn't get the last
name right heidi tremarco
okay
my apologies
i have
hello so i um i'm sending around the
written remarks but i believe they were
also emailed to the committee
on april 1st from my colleague peter
blair
and so
clf is here to oppose this bill which is
really you know the name advanced
recycling should really be seen for what
it is which is a greenwashing
description of this bill you've heard
today it described as a high heat
thermal process it is a burning of
plastics
and it is not recycling in fact you've
been told it's not recycling they want
it to be called manufacturing
so this is not an advanced recycling
bill despite the name
clf supports recycling and you've heard
today there's many things we need to do
to reduce the amount of plastics that
are going into our landfills and there
are solutions out there we'd love for
those the committee to consider those
you know there's uh composting extended
producer responsibility
um source reduction there's a bottle
bill there's a lot of things that can be
done that we know work
this is not one of them this is there's
a lot of unknown um with this bill as
you as you've heard today and
there's no reason why this technology
should be deregulated by the state
we weren't able to hear any reason
really articulated why
this process can't go forward under the
current regulations and why the american
chemistry council is pushing for
deregulation
of this plastics
and we should be really wary of that
this is a dangerous process with a lot
of environmental externalities and we
have these documented in our comments
but you know just to call out part of
them like traditional waste incineration
this process creates a significant
environmental harm they emit just as
much carbon dioxide as waste
incinerators and they admit air
emissions that contain heavy metals like
lead and mercury as well as other toxics
they can include pcbs
hydrogen cyanide carbon monoxide
nitrogen sulfur dioxides this is not a
there it is not a clean process there's
a lot of environmental externalities
and
as you've heard today northern new
england states are doing this and
specifically similar bills to deregulate
this burning of plastic under the guise
of advanced recycling has been brought
forward and rejected in connecticut
rhode island and massachusetts so the
other new england states are saying we
don't want this dirty process in our
state and what will happen if new
hampshire does this deregulation is you
can you will see
these wastes being sent to new hampshire
we already import 50 percent of our
waste that goes into our landfills from
out of state new hampshire does not want
to keep attracting the other the waste
and
finally
as we look at this new or emerging
technology and we look at all these
questions that came up today that we
keep saying you know are really
technical questions that need to be
considered further new hampshire has a
solid waste working group that is
looking at
these issues and can specifically
address this bill came up at the last
meeting of new hampshire solid waste
working group and we know that the state
department of environmental services is
updating the state solid waste plan
currently we're operating under a plan
that the state produced in 2003 and des
was supposed to update that plan every
six years and they haven't done so now
they tell us that they are
we are on the cusp of a new plan that a
new plan is coming out in october um
director wimsat testified to that in uh
previous hearings in the past couple
weeks so des says that we're going to
have a new state solid waste plan in
october
and so i respectfully say that while we
await that new plan it is inexpedient to
move forward on this bill and to
deregulate this burning of plastics and
so
we suggest that the committee move the
bill is inexpedient to legislate
i can take any questions
thank you any questions
representative bixby yeah so you re you
reference extended producer
responsibility as one alternative for
dealing with plastics so if
uh a
if if an industry
takes back their single use plastics
after they're being used what do they do
well there's a myriad of things the
industry
could do with them i'm not sure i
understand okay so i guess
they're going the if the if the industry
takes back their single-use plastics
they're going to need to have some
mechanism
for breaking those down into something
that is once again usable
and i'm wondering if
this
if
pyrolysis which does in fact not use
oxygen and therefore does not create
carbon dioxide
if pyrolysis is not is taken off the
table
then how are they going to convert those
single-use plastics which are generally
in the category of difficult to deal
with plastics how are they going to
manage to
turn those into something useful well
certainly
there's nothing if this bill fails to go
forward that doesn't need pyrolysis is
taken off the table for all what this
does is it deregulates these plastic
feed stock as solid waste so it doesn't
mean that
those that technology can't be explored
further and i think it should be
explored further by the working group
and by des and the experts should weigh
in on the viability of that process
follow it so
if this process is
largely an industrial manufacturing
process
would it make more sense to have it
regulated under
the
regulations that cover manufacturers
i don't think
um
so the question is would it make more
sense to regulate as manufacturing yeah
i mean currently this the this is waste
that goes into the feedstock
and so
i'm sorry i don't think i'm following
okay so
the the material that that is going into
these plants
uh could either be classified as solid
waste
and would have one set of regulations
applied to it such as keeping rats out
or
it would could be treated as a
raw material raw material for a
manufacturing process and that
manufacturing process would have
regulations that deal with things like
clean air both at the federal and state
level uh clean water st
state and federal level uh and the
disposal of
uh
of what would be the char or slag or
whatever that is that that
20 that was referenced as not being
reusable
so
would it make more sense to regulate
this uh under manufacturing rules rather
than solid waste rules
i'm hesitant to say to regulate this
because i don't think the bill is clear
what falls into which category and when
as you asked earlier when it when the
waste transitions from being waste to
this feedstock and so
uh
i think this is just another unknown you
know we have current regulations in
place and there's no reason to to wave
them and deregulate but i can um try to
i can take that question back as well
and just provide more information you
know i can try to see if i can get a
more detailed answer but right now i
think it's too undefined okay follow-up
sure one more so um in the pro point uh
i think that one thing that i'd like to
have answered in that follow-up is what
do not yet exist for the manufacturing
processes involved in pyrolysis
and advanced recycling
that would need to be in place in order
what sorts of regulations do not yet
exist in regards to pyrolysis
that need to be in place in order to
make it safe okay i will take that
question back thank you good response to
you
any further questions representative
kennedy
thank you for taking my question des has
stated that they are comfortable with
this language
why
i want to say why do you disagree with
the fact that they are comfortable with
the language if they have worked with
the senate on it
and this is now what we have in front of
us
i can't i can't test i can't explain why
des says they're comfortable uh
deregulating this waste but it raises a
red flag to me that des is willing to
waive that authority and to and to
weaken as you said as you heard before
the language has been weakened as it
went through the senate and i think that
is really concerning um and
des
they
they didn't they weren't able to provide
any reason why the waste should be
deregulated and why this process should
be deregulated and so i don't it's hard
to explain why they're taking that
position
so so i'm not going to speak for des
specifically but as you are aware i am
the representative for the house and the
solid waste working group and this bill
did come up and
what uh director wim said
certainly conveyed to the working group
was that they were comfortable that
the wording within the bill gave them
the power to
or the authority excuse me to go in and
inspect these facilities and one of
their major concerns was in the event
that a facility failed and there were
still some of this solid waste that had
not been processed on site would they
have the ability to go in and manage and
regulate the
appropriate dispersal of things that
were still might be considered solid
waste within that facility so that that
was one of the things that director wims
had touched on directly
go ahead if you want to and i just
i think des needs to do the planning
work first and they're engaged in that
planning and we're told it's coming
right now so
there's this is putting the cart before
the horse you know this is like issuing
landfill permits relying on an outdated
solid waste plan we need to do the
planning first and decide what direction
the state wants to go
before we start deregulating certain
procedures
any further questions
all right seeing none thank you we
okay next we'll uh call and i believe
it's nancy morrison i'm sorry
if i
i'm trying to read the writing here and
hopefully i got it right i didn't have
thank you welcome to ena
i'm sorry i said welcome to ena go ahead
thank you thank you for
listening to me today i'm nancy morrison
from mont vernon new hampshire
i'll be very brief because mostly the
things i would like to say have been
said
and i'm not as eloquent as speaker as
some of the ones you've heard today
but i am here to
give an opinion as a citizen
that new hampshire and the world needs
less plastic
not creating more from old plastic
that is highly energy intensive to
create actually 87 times
higher than the energy it would give if
it was made into fuel
and
creates often inferior products
and adds pollution to our world in the
form of dioxins pfas and metals
i would encourage all of you to take
this very very slowly as has been
mentioned
this
industry is relatively new
and
states have adopted it but they've
struggled with it and from what i have
read and researched there has been
moderate success at best
i encourage all of you to
google a report by
reuters
in november of last year 2021
and i think it will help you to balance
some of the things you heard from the
acc in order to get
two sides to the coin it's an excellent
article
but basically i believe we are swapping
pollution from the ground to the air and
the trading one evil for another is
where this would be at right now i feel
like it's just too early to take this on
and more research needs to be done and a
study group is a great idea for you
folks
but plastic reduction is the answer
and with respect to rev representative
avard
advanced recycling is a plan but it's
it's a bad plan right now for new
hampshire
so
with that i thank you for listening to
me will you take questions oh
and are there any questions from the
committee all right seeing none i guess
you're off the hook
thank you for coming in
all right i'm on my last card if there's
anyone else who
wants to speak get a card in quickly
because i'm going to close right after
this if i don't have any more uh kirsten
thank you for coming in welcome to the
good afternoon mr chair members of the
committee my name is kirsten koch and
i'm the director of public policy for
the business and industry association
also known as bia i'm here today to
express bia support for senate bill 367.
this bill furthers environmental
sustainability and brings economic
benefits to new hampshire
we believe that this bill furthers the
state's solid waste management goals by
preventing many traditionally hard to
recycle plastics from going into new
hampshire landfills instead these
advanced recycling facilities can
manufacture these products
into a variety of reusable materials we
believe it's time to welcome these
manufacturers with this technology into
new hampshire in order to divert solid
waste from landfills and begin
developing a more robust recycling
market in new england
senate bill 367 also encourages advanced
recycling facilities to come to new
hampshire for business ultimately
bringing more jobs to the local economy
on a variety of levels
this bill provides regulatory certainty
for advanced recycling facilities the
main function of these facilities is to
manufacture new materials not to manage
the disposal of waste new hampshire
should welcome sustainable business and
we believe that these facilities should
be regulated as what they are which is
manufacturers
we respectfully request this committee
to pass senate bill 367 because
it would further environmental
sustainability and
increase economic opportunities for the
state of new hampshire thank you for
your consideration and i'd be glad to
try to answer any of your questions
thank you sorry about getting your last
name wrong that's okay
any questions
from the committee
representative duttsy
thank you for taking my question
what professionals does the bia have on
its staff
to be able to
understand the environmental impact of
so for staff um i mean for these issues
we consult with our members and our
experts and so um we've been consulting
with chemistry experts in order to
further understand this bill that's part
of our membership
thank you for your question
thank you any further questions
seeing none thank you for coming in
thank you
okay
anybody else that wants to testify on
do you have to state your name and i'm
going to ask you to fill out a pink card
when you're sorry well thank you
chairman pearl i i had planned not to
speak to this because frankly i don't
know enough about it the more i've
listened to it today could you state
your name excuse me my name is fred
anderson i'm from whitefield
i
we sort our trash we recycle we compost
i'm married to a woman who is a plastic
nazi
i was born before plastic
i know what it means to live in a world
without plastic and frankly we can and
frankly we probably can live there
better
but when i hear
oh this is we can turn it from fuel we
can turn it into products it sounds like
a dream it sounds like the absolute
solution
the devil is in the details friends so i
simply urge you as the responsible
people you are on either side of the
aisle here we learned that from you in
terms of other things and the work we've
done with you
take your time
what's the rush
if this can be done
improve it and let's go for it we'll all
benefit but for heaven's sakes don't
make a mistake that's going to put more
stuff in the air that's going to have to
be dealt with one way or another and we
will not benefit from it so as i said i
didn't plan to say anything to you but
thank you so much
thank you anybody else that wishes to
speak
all right seeing none i'm going to read
10 folks signed in on the blue sheet all
opposed and give me a second i'm going
to get the online one there's 11 online
there's 11 in support and 142 in
opposition
with that i'm going to close the hearing
on uh senate bill 367.
so i will schedule a uh work session on
this at some point we'll have to we got
to figure that out and i don't know when
it'll be but uh
we'll have to keep your eye on the
calendar and we'll we'll get something
designed for the committee benefit of
the committee we will be having hearings
next tuesday on april 12th and we'll
also have a presentation scheduled on
that day beginning at 9 00 a.m so but
keep your eye on the calendar i will get
all that together and we'll get it out
to you so
beyond that anything else from the
committee before i close representative
bixby
just want to
remind the chair that in addition to
having the hearings next tuesday because
we are hearing a couple early bills
there will also be execs on those they
will be thank you for reminding me of
that that was the other point we will be
doing some exact work next week because
we were given
two early bills
rather late over the weekend and i was
not able to get them into this week's
hearings so we're going to have to hear
them and exec them next tuesday so for
the benefit of the committee i
want to give you a heads up that that's
coming
anything further i've forgotten
i don't think so all right with that we
will
he's